All right, let's use these games and
screens to create a game with multiple
different screens it can display.
Instead of a ApplicationAdapter here,
we're using a Game.
If we right click on Game,
and say Go To > Declaration,
we can jump into the source code
of the Game class inside LibGDX.
As we see,
Game implements ApplicationListener.
It seems that the Game class has
a screen member variable, and then for
each one of
the ApplicationListener callbacks,
if it has a screen it then delegates
that callback to the screen.
Here we've declared two screens,
one of which displays the number
of frames displayed per second.
And the other display is the number of
seconds between the current frame and
the last one.
To set the active screen, we just
need to call set screen on our game.
Let's check out delta screen.
>> Screens are very similar to
application listeners with a couple
differences.
Instead of create,
screens get a show call.
Screens can receive a hide call when
another screen becomes active and
the render call received by a screen
includes this argument called delta.
The argument delta is the number
of seconds after the previous
frame that this frame is
expected to hit the screen.
In a normal game running
at 60 frames per second,
this will be approximately 0.0167
seconds or 16.7 milliseconds.
However if your game is running on
old hardware or is just trying to
draw way too much stuff you may
end up with a delta that's larger.
In this screen we've created a bitmap
font and a sprite batch, and
we're just displaying the delta that's
been passed into the rendered callback.
Also we've included logging on
all of the life cycle methods so
that we can investigate what
happens when we switch screens.